this report is really helpful in sort of
splitting out some of the issues
relating to theft which i think most of
us would think relates to items of
property uh i mean inanimate objects and
the real emotional uh harm that can be
caused to owners and indeed to the
animals themselves if they are taken
away from their homes and
i think the approach of the task force
to look at this more akin to a cruelty
type offense i think is a very sensible
when your animals are living things we
have a responsibility to them for their
welfare uh they are sentient beings and
therefore i think the use of the term
abduction is a far better way of
describing the overall criminality here
and the impact not just on individual
owners but wider society bearing in mind
some of the worrying reports that we've
heard uh in recent months
can we explain exactly why there has
been such such an explosion in thefts of
this type but particularly over the
course of the pandemic
well i think ownership has increased you
know a lot of us were alone a lot of us
were isolated and having the uh the
warmth and companionship of a pet
has led to a rise in pet ownership about
one in two of us now owning a pet here
in the uk
the evidence relating to
the taking of pets has been
widespread
the data that we have is not as robust
as it should be and therefore one of the
recommendations is for the police across
the country to improve the way they
record these crimes and to do more work
in terms of raising awareness and
preventative work as well i was
particularly struck by the excellent
recommendations about
more improvements in the way that
animals are microchipped and the
information that is recorded about them
to make it easier to detect uh these
crimes when they're committed